And we will hear testimony today concerning recent revelations about a purportedly secret UAP program
whose existence and findings may have been improperly withheld from Congress.
This is going to be the original document about Immaculate Constellation.
Those of us who have been following this very closely have been hearing whispers of the words Immaculate Constellation for a few months now.
The Immaculate Constellation, it's a UAP reconnaissance program.
I can affirm this 100%.
What is in here is wild.
I mean, they're saying, I'm paraphrasing, but reports of F-22s getting like boxed in by flying orbs that they couldn't shake.
There were satellite images or satellite image of a football field sized flying saucer hiding in clouds.
I have personally walked people into members offices for private meetings so they could see eye to eye and they could meet.
You are the author of what the world knows as the Immaculate Constellation report.
It has been allowed to corrupt and infest every aspect of our society to serve the interests and whims of a very elite select few.
The following is an interview with the author of the Immaculate Constellation report that was submitted into congressional record.
Is it ironic you have to put your face out with us to protect yourself at this point?
That's what we're doing, right?
Yeah, that's what we're doing.
This is absolutely wild.
This is what I did not want to do.
You've worked in secret programs.
You've got clearances.
You've made oaths that you would keep secrets.
Let's talk about secrecy and the UAP topic.
Shouldn't it be secret to some degree?
I mean, we have there's a race for the technology to try to understand it.
We have adversary nations who'd love to get it ahead of us.
Why not keep this stuff secret?
Well, if it was just technology that we are worried about protecting and maintaining military advantage.
And, you know, there's strong arguments to be made and have successfully been made for decades in this country that the American leadership and American people seem to be finding acceptable to be left in the dark about, you know, where science, technology and their military is taking them.
This isn't just technology.
This isn't something somebody came up with in a lab and it's sensitive because once the cats have the bag, anybody can do it fundamentally.
This comes from in a secondary to.
Yeah.
Okay.
You've been told is the biggest question, which is, is humanity alone?
The answer is no.
And the secrecy that has been defended is at the cost of, in my mind, human dignity, freedom and progress.
And it is no longer permissible or acceptable in my mind to to continue this course to deprive another generation of not just Americans, but humanity.
Or their birthright to know.
Who they are, where they came from and what's with us.
Can you give us a general description of the size of the secrecy apparatus?
You know, we're going to drill down to this, of course, about income, income and one particular facet of the secrecy that you came across and other parts of it.
But how big of a secrecy apparatus is it?
How many stovepipes are there?
How many people are involved in different ways of keeping this secret, confusing the public, lying to Congress, lying to the world?
Simply put, it's a parallel reality.
The secrecy apparatus is all pervasive.
It is not just in the intelligence community governing their world.
It's not just in the military protecting their operations.
It's not protecting our diplomats and leaders as they conduct their work, sometimes in very dangerous places.
It has been allowed to corrupt and infest every aspect of our society.
Uh.
To serve the interests and whims of a very elite, select few.
And it's been used to intimidate, threaten, destroy the lives of people like yourselves who have been doing their job, keeping their oaths, trying to protect their country, being true to humanity and paid prices for it.
Absolutely.
This has been a difficult process for you, for me and you, you know, kind of going through this.
I've seen what you've gone through.
Personally, with this, you're taking a personal hit, like a painful risk, just talking to us, just doing this.
Finally, after all this time, I think I understand why you're explaining something philosophical, what you believe about the secrecy, just personally, like, what is the step for you to do this?
Like, why?
I need to understand why.
Why are you telling this to everybody now?
Now, there's no short answer.
It's something.
You know, I have many, not even competing, but parallel motivations.
But why now look out at the world, look inside our country?
We are not headed to a good future.
You're concerned.
I am.
Explain the concern.
Ultimately, my biggest fear is what humanity will do to itself out of fear and greed.
And what we have done, and we have built a prison around ourselves, it's invisible, but it's not complete, and there is still time to maybe alter our trajectory, have a different future, may not be the best one that we had hoped for, but it's going to be damn sight better than what they have planned for us.
You know, there's no going back after you tell us this on camera.
We had this conversation.
This is it.
This is the line in the sand.
You're about to cross over here.
Absolutely.
I am on a personal level giving up the future that I made for myself and was going to try to make for a family.
I'm proud of what I accomplished in my time in government, and it's painful to leave the good people there and to know that there really isn't room for people to act according to their conscience.
No, no.
There is nothing wrong with that, but if I don't do it and I'm permissive enough, there is no point.
Well, so that is that message.
It was all your own leaders, right?
They had nothing wrong.
I will tell you.
Yes.
As long as you inanimate it.
But if that makes a difference to you, that is very much part of the role that you play in any story, and they have been recognizing this as far as modern science actually is concerned, as quite appropriate as it may be, because just the fact that there is still somebody doing things that no one often urges to do that.
exposed to that you've seen people you've talked to and communicated with over a period of a couple
of years is your belief that this the technology the race for the technology the understanding of
the big secret is entirely in the hands of people outside the government and not for the benefit of
the public or to protect american national security it's it's in some other realm in some
other hands i think it's a mix um you know i think our military you know has a long historic
involvement in this so does our intelligence community and our scientific academic community
we have as a country allowed ourselves to be penetrated co-opted and corrupted
by an internationalist force that serves their interests and views nations peoples
as as tools and means to an end like a business cabal international corporations that have no
loyalty to any nation let alone this one that's a large part of it
i think uh we go have to go above that too to like start to explain the the degree of the level
of deception and the level of commitment they've had to maintaining that deception it's above just
monetary gain and power they're afraid george and i've talked about whistleblowers that come to us
and we protect them we don't often report on when people come to us um we're doing this now
you know what are the repercussions people talk about whistleblowers
being afraid and there's one set of being afraid which is uh when you're squeezed by outside
entities you know that are fucking with you which has happened to you we'll talk about that but what
are the just the legal implications of what you're about to talk to us today tell me the gravity right
now what are you facing what i want our audience to understand what it means for you to talk to us
right now what could happen to you my uh hope is that the stakes are uh not paid out um but
they are life imprisonment and the possibility of execution and you've tried all the right ways
i've helped you on some of the we've tried you have tried all the right ways to do this but you
have something much bigger that that is pushing on you that you have to take this next step forward
and so now i just want people to understand where you're coming from we say we protect whistleblowers
when people come to us not everybody goes on camera but also just you work uh currently in
department of state and you're not the only one who's coming to us and you're not the only one who's
in charge of the state but maybe he should tell us his history yeah let's do uh chronological so
you got a degree in what uh so i got a degree in international affairs came out to dc started
working in a small think tank uh from there i uh applied to and was accepted to a intelligence
agency ended up taking a job uh at the at the pentagon um basically waiting for the right
opportunity for that world to to pop up um
um what was which one it did uh i you know was having too much fun so i said no you're in the
pentagon weapons of mass destruction as a general umbrella under which you're you're working did you
got a security clearance at that point yeah i had been cleared by dia for a top secret uh sci
clearance you get to see i guess firsthand all this different information that comes in from
all over these places different platforms and right you're exposed to that and you get an idea
of just how big that apparatus is yes yes absolutely um ufos and aliens aside it's a it
it's a different world without anything exotic in it when you are exposed and to that information
and learning over time not just from the intelligence but the experiences of the people
around you because uh not everything that's true and has happened in the world is written down on
paper i mean you've given a lot of roles and responses
it gives you access to very sensitive information when you said sci that's secret compartmentalized
information is the acronym sensitive compartmentalized information i always yeah it's
probably right yeah so you know about me but i'm just saying you know you are a sane human being
you're given a lot of these responsibilities um you know you i just think it's important for
people to understand so you have access to very critical information through the united states
government they're separate from the ufos and the aliens and they're separate from the aliens and
you know topic that we're going to talk about for the world for the world of us in the world yes and
that weighs heavy on you i'm sure like you're you're really looking to defend the united states
of america where you live and you are looking at information that is just highly sensitive i think
it's important for people to know good people like you doing great jobs in there you had access and
responsibilities people trust you we that that's you can't get there without that it is um yeah
it's a very uh
burdensome uh role i i feel deeply for the people who have been there for many years
um a lot of hidden suffering that comes from it but it is uh you know i i thought it was
a noble and good mission i still do and risks i imagine there's all kinds of information that
comes across your desk and that desk of other people you're working with at that point about
weapons of mass destruction the movement of nuclear weapons or suddenly material that
disappears and where did he go black market um and i think that's a very important part of the
uh biological weapons research things that are going on around the world that we need to keep an
eye on right yeah and things that never make the news uh you're absolutely right yeah there there
is uh like i said there is a whole many there's many worlds there's many shells to our reality
that the public including our professional media class our professional academic class
our political class has absolutely no idea exists and if they do have
idea they have a very distorted one sometimes intentionally so i mean you're not like um some
secret agent you're not like some say secret agent so like so people understand when you're
working in at the pentagon is where we're at in the thing i mean this is we have a lot of great
people that are bright-minded working on these problems for the united states keeping the united
states safe looking at geopolitical aspects of nuclear weaponry that kind of thing but just to
be clear i mean you're not some secret agent with more access than anybody else or anything like
that no i uh
never uh wanted to be a field officer i danced with the idea in my dreams maybe and read the
books but uh i knew that wasn't for me um especially the the the task and the cost of
befriending and manipulating and ultimately using people um i don't think i would have been very good
at that like human human intelligence yeah false friendship exactly does that stuff come across
your desk human intelligence
signals intelligence regarding weapons of mass all sources all sources intelligent all sources of
intelligence um and if there are questions you can go ask them and usually get the answers and the
kinds of things that you see that come across your desk does it give you pause how am i going to sleep
that i know and that this xyz is going on somewhere uh at times when they think oh we
crap how did this happen everyone has like their different standard of what's going to you know
shake them like that and i've definitely had a few of those um
i won't share them but yeah but i mean just with security bring national security kind of stuff
right stuff unrelated to exotic things that are very just world out there okay you're there for
a while you do that for how many years oh see i was in there a little over four years but i was
in the pentagon a little over five because i moved uh out of there briefly into uh the
undersecretary of defense for intelligence and a smaller office in there we've heard of that office
we have heard of that office um what and what
was a different sort of work or the same thing just for a different ball same field uh different
work different boss different community so you're working for a contractor but you're working at the
pentagon on pentagon business and that's sort of a model that is used for all kinds of programs right
yeah um that's that's the industry in dc is that they have a buffer of some sort why why is it why
is that necessary well you have government management and they're supposed to be the
ones that you know they sign the checks make the final decisions but
yeah most of the staff is contractors military people on detail people on fellowships from you
know either think tanks or universities um so you get to be familiar with snow pipes and how you know
you could be working on this and the guy may be in the office next to you or the desk next to you is
working on something else and you don't know what they're working on yeah i mean it can be that way
uh my experience was more that we had a team it was all more or less on the same information level
there'd be other teams that yeah they have their own so it's not quite uh as isolated i've heard
from others it can be just you know it's you and no one else around you knows what you're doing um
you got a company it's a contractor that's working there in the pentagon how much oversight is there
from the actual pentagon the military of a contractor's work well i mean the day-to-day
is overseen by the government um so in that sense it's it's there and is that generally
true for all the contractor programs that we'll be getting into later
somebody in the military or ic is is looking at what that contractor does
no i couldn't say right yeah i could not say we got the one degree and then you you went on to
try to get a master's yeah i went to george washington university uh masters of security
policy study uh got to the point where i had a thesis to submit uh and then i started working
at the pentagon i took a break and uh kind of got caught up in the churn as the term is right i'm
curious about just what it's like to work at the pentagon i mean to think you're driving to work
there it is the heart and soul of the national security of our country uh you're doing important
work weapons of mass destruction in the biggest office building in the world uh i would think
it'd be a lot of satisfaction in that but i wonder what day-to-day is like are you under
surveillance do you have to do polygraphs can you tell your wife what you're doing
do you uh socialize with colleagues or do you have to worry about what you say to whom and where yeah
so i mean started with the first part um i think for me at least yeah it was like i finally made
it right i'm at i'm working out the pentagon uh i it's cheesy but i felt pride pretty much every
single day that i rolled in there that's not cheesy and uh it was i was very fortunate to
join a uh an office that cared a lot about their people not just um their performance at work but uh
their goals their desires and how they were getting on uh with life in general um fewer
places are like that um but i look back on that time with a lot of with a lot of happiness
how do things begin to sour is it because of this topic that we're going to discuss yes let's take
it from there when does that start what what's your first exposure i mean were you like a ufo guy
like before i mean like there's something that happened and there's always an instigator right
but it's like um
you know were you like a ufo guy all your years back or to some degree i've always been interested
in aliens and ufos uh secret histories the things that are hidden from us it's been a lifelong kind
of passion it's not always aliens you know while i was always interested in these things they were
never they were only a realm of possible and when i looked at ufos in a serious way as i was more uh
in my like college years
i got ex just not exposure but uh i started learning about the sort of ecosystem of secrecy
uh in the military industrial complex uh what saps are what caps are and you you start to realize
like oh yeah there's a good chance a lot of what these ufo things are are some really cool stuff
that we have uh whether it's in the air under the water or uh right in front of you you're
not getting a job at the pentagon because you want to get access to the ufo scene no no when i joined
you know i pretty much locked down that you know there might be life out there but most i think
most what we're seeing in the skies at that time i thought was either ours or
uh ally or adversary you don't go over the deep end you're not going to move on conferences
you're not wearing a beanie and alien stuff on your head no no in fact uh you know i would be
looked at like i had a third eye just by suggesting there were stealth satellites
i mean in fact like you've never been to like a ufo conference or anything like that have you no
that's not your style no you're a very analytically minded person it's something i've learned um
i bet you're really good at your job because just the way our communications the way you
deep dive into research that's a talent to be able to pull a lot big source information
all source information and kind of come to conclusions you that you that is one of your
skill sets yeah absolutely um did you ever work nine to five because you're kind of a workaholic
right and you go over the top yeah yeah um you know i really like the truth about the ufo and i'm
the one that's gonna be talking about it tonight and i'm gonna be talking about it tonight and i'm
so excited because it's only been on mcdonald's ever since i saw that one i'm
gonna be talking about it at the end of my career and you know this is such a good thing that i'm
You know, I really liked the Pentagon. I learned an immense amount there, and I would stay there till the wee hours of the morning learning.
Which is also how you found out information about the topic we're going to discuss.
I delved too deeply.
And you came across this sort of accident?
100% accidentally. Well, sorry. The Immaculate Constellation piece of this, 100% accidentally.
Before I was exposed to that, you know, I had seen UAP on military videos in the Pentagon, but nothing that suggested, you know, origin, intent, or in the level of detail that I came to find later.
So explain that to the average person. Like, how do you just come across UFO videos in the Pentagon? What does that mean? Tell somebody who has no idea how that happens.
Yes. So you have a clearance, and there's a secret internet. And on that secret internet, there's just a generic access like UNI. It's all very secret, sensitive stuff, but more or less, everyone can look at what's on there.
Then, you know, you have on this secret internet, some compartmentation, light compartmentation, as it were.
And then there's entirely...
There's entirely different systems for truly, truly sensitive stuff. But the point is, is that there is essentially, you know, a shared community of knowledge. And it goes back, you know, just like our own internet, it goes back over decades.
If you have a top secret clearance, you go on JWICs, you can pretty much go and see whatever is on there, except for special compartmentalized stuff.
Yeah, pretty much. Or things that, you know, are just people protect their business processes.
Who would be putting UFO type or UAP videos on there? How does that happen? How do they end up there?
Service members and intelligence officers, who for one reason or another, decided to put that footage there.
What's the first UFO video you see? What would you think of it? Or military film footage of a UFO? What did you... What was that like?
Well, technically, the first true, like, military footage was...
That I saw was that Tic Tac video and the Go Fast video. And I think there's one other else, the Gimbal video that all came out in 2017. Granted, I didn't see those on military systems, but just being precise here.
Yeah.
And so things that I saw after that kind of looked like all that, but just much more duration. The videos, you know, it's the internet, whether it's secret or not.
There's compression, there's upload and file sizes. So some things are crystal clear, but it's only 15 seconds. Some things you can see 45 minutes of something moving around, but it's kind of blurry because that's a lot of data.
So you've seen crystal clear at times videos of what appear to be, would you say, non-human intelligence made craft? I mean, you see evidence that the rest of the world doesn't get to see. That starts happening.
Yeah. Nothing in those videos necessarily proves it's extraterrestrial.
Interterrestrial or non-human. It certainly is anomalous, exotic, and unexplainable.
And advanced.
Yes.
Beyond our capabilities that you know of?
I don't know. Some of it might have been within our capabilities to replicate, even in an inferior manner. But quite a lot of it, you know, it's either something else, or we live in a world where we have been left behind.
2017.
These stories come out, New York Times and other media. The videos become known. That sparked your curiosity and you start looking around for that kind of stuff? Or it would just come across your desk in front of your eyes naturally?
Yeah. So not looking for that stuff.
Did you have access to live feeds?
Yes.
So live feeds, real time, you could go into like a Reaper drone and see if there's something going on. Just, I mean, not that you're specifically looking for UFOs, but you had access even to live feeds.
Yeah.
Um, you know, not anything special, no special access, but you know, you, you know, where those resources are, you can go look at them. And I did.
Um, I want to go back to this. You said with these nuclear facilities, nuclear weapons, nuclear labs, nuclear power plants within a year or two, like, are you saying all of them get visited? Or are there some strange phenomena?
I can't say that they all do, but I would, I would suspect that, you know, anything that is.
Uh, sufficiently nuclear, uh, we'll draw attention at some point and we'll be, uh, they will be encountering this.
And what are they? What do you see it? What kinds of things are you seeing?
So, I mean, nothing too dramatic when it comes to like these facilities. A lot of times it's, it's porbs of, uh, you know, it's hard to always judge the size, but I'd be surprised if it's bigger than a Cessna, probably something somewhere in between, um, whether it's white or silver-ish.
Yeah.
Or if you're looking through different sensor apparati, uh, it'll, you know, look like whatever hot or cold is, uh, um, but usually orbs around these facilities. Sometimes things that look a bit more irregular, um, but the vast majority being orbs.
I mean, the world's been exposed to some of this. There's been a clarification to the general public about what are you seeing when you're seeing infrared or FLIR. It takes some translation. There are people that focus on that and like they can read that.
Yeah.
But basically,
Um, you're looking at things that don't have flight control surfaces that don't have traditional propulsion. They seem to tag along with, which we've heard forever with nuclear events and that kind of thing, nuclear structure.
Mm-hmm.
Um, but you, you, you see a lot of these, you start getting exposed to them. I mean, just to begin, doesn't that, does that start or doesn't that start to kind of, um, feed that curiosity in you? You just all of a sudden, the average person, but you're now seeing stuff that you can't.
Yeah.
You have to be a special kind of boring to not be interested after seeing those states. It's shocking, especially knowing the context of what you're looking at.
Right. Which you get when you have those systems that can look at that.
A hundred percent.
What's the context with like the big picture? Like what's, what's the context?
Yeah. And in this, in this way, it, you seeing images, is there discussion? Is there text that comes along with us? Hey, we, we saw this thing. What the hell is it? It's not us.
Surprisingly little of that. I think, um, the community kind of knows.
We're new. We don't talk about this. It's there. Um, you know, that changed, uh, some years ago, but it's since been, I think, uh, shut down again in terms of like, you know, community participation and solving the problem.
So people within the intelligence community know you don't talk about this out loud. You don't say the quiet part out loud. You post stuff, you kind of get, then you get an era of discussion when this starts coming forward, 2017, New York times.
But then you're, you're explaining that there's been a kind of clamp down on that dialogue and discussion. I've heard that from a lot of people on the inside. You witnessed that too?
Uh, yes, absolutely. Both firsthand and from, you know, hearing from friends and connections.
Yeah.
So, uh, the screws were tightened and, um, certain agencies, you're not allowed to mention certain whistleblowers names or you'll be fired immediately.
So there's no announcement on the PA system. There's no, uh, leaflets left in the cafeteria.
No memo put out that says, don't talk about this stuff, but you know.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, you can pick up on that vibe real quick.
When you say there's certain whistleblowers names, you can't mention. This brings me back to a friend of ours went when George is doing his news report on Bob Lazar. First time I was going to air. He just said when he was up at area 52, he just said, Hey, you should pay attention to the news.
His career was over. He got pulled into room the next day. I would call him a friend of ours. Um, I interviewed him about it. I mean, that was done.
He just mentioned that.
To watch George's news report. Again, we're not equating Bob Lazar to, to, to anything, but we were just saying that happened. So what do you mean if you mentioned certain whistleblowers? Who?
David Grush.
You can't mention David Grush in certain professional settings or you are fucked.
Yeah. If you're not fired, you are, uh, in for a very rough time is my understanding.
Elizondo?
You know, I didn't hear Elizondo as a no-go word.
Saying David Grush. Look, David Grush testified in open Congress.
Okay.
That makes sense. So what, have you seen it happen? Have you seen people like mention his name? How do you become a way you can't even talk about him?
So that specific, uh, example, uh, heard from a friend at that agency, that was essentially the, uh, word of mouth from management, nothing written in paper, nothing in emails, but from what it sounds like, uh, people got a conversation with their leadership and were told as much as we just gone over.
Um, and his name was absolutely the firsthand experience.
Yeah.
Sort of radioactive in the chat rooms.
It would either all of a sudden, these people that, um, never participate, are there really slamming him and slamming the people talking about him on the classified internet?
Indeed.
Our space is one we've talked about a bunch, but these, these were people who had open dialogue.
It just got a clamp down and his name was part of that.
That's what you meant when you said certain people are radioactive.
You can't mention their names.
Right.
Okay.
Who does?
Yeah.
No, we're nuclear.
He's radioactive with different designation.
Yeah.
So you're seeing these.
videos and some limited discussion you can't really openly talk about it but you're curious
you're you're kind of hooked on the topic yeah and and to be clear uh uh 2018 when this first
exposure happened and for about a few years after it was it did at least feel more open looking back
on it this was probably a counterintelligence prerogative at the time um but it was allowed
to exist the discussion was allowed to exist and it felt more like you know people were excited to
finally actually be able to talk about this and finally be able to try to compare notes
figure it out well that's when the uap task force was created they didn't call it that but it was
up and running and they were trying to make entreaties out to the intelligence community
and dod hey they wanted input from and old and partners yeah so i i saw that emerge and i saw
it die it's all die and when you say exposure we're going to get into this but you mean
technically it's called spillage it's when you see something that is of a
compartmentalized or nature that you are not specifically cleared to see and you were
exposed to something and it was like holy shit what is this and the first thoughts of that i'm
interested in so if we're at that point yeah okay so let's talk about that look the whole world
knows about imcon immaculate constellation we're saying that word out loud um at one time that was
very dangerous to say out loud to write to text we should talk about that but before this is your
entrance point what happened how did it happen what did you see what did you think yeah so
the first exposure uh or the exposure to immaculate constellation uh happened on a
shared server that was shared by all the offices in osd um what i was doing throughout what i was
doing at the time was opening files that were clearly misfiled and either sorting them to
our offices uh you know part of that uh server or
putting them in their own box to be sorted by other responsible your jobs i mean this is more
like volunteer duty but yes so because you're a workaholic and you're curious and you read a lot
um you come across a file that really is what leads us to being here today it's uh this it's
the schreiber file yeah so it was labeled um 2018 schreiber war game might have been brief
or something else but that's it um
there's nothing about that that screams you know it's a very interesting thing in fact usually a
lot of war game briefs are pretty boring um so there's nothing that stood out about it
accidental exposure for you 100 you you go into it and what do you see uh there's just a generic
title slide there's a banner without classification markings that just says
immaculate constellation and it has a placeholder slide that shows like the schreiber orbit or
schreiber airbase and the schreiber airbase and the schreiber airbase and the schreiber airbase and
some GitHub學고 go and the some logos of the units involved but at that time I believe it would
have still been like Air force space command adjacent uh so it's still nothing particularly
uh stunning I think the name at the top probably just the name of the exercise
they were jumping away with some dog so I just wanted to note that I'm your first sì
erendane that the guys on carry cats have something toCI
those where it gets interesting uh because the face of Lou Elizondo is on that next slide
and i was not who I missed urnal which on y'd we record few moments in x highlight
was being sent to the room and it was favoura bar for every single speaking Frühling
before the single patriot r equipo battle right so we're just as − a first we should say
pads in the mood a dog who needed help cause life breadati
we learned the tropics he and I as not really well well as well asvey
by text. To summarize, please have some grace with me, it's been seven years, but it was
saying that Immaculate Constellation is an unacknowledged special access program established
after the exposure of AATIP in 2017 by former USDI officer Lou Elizondo. And, you know,
that's the gist of that first slide. And so I'm looking at that, and, you know, nothing
particularly convincing that that's alien related, or what the SAP is, or what it's doing.
So I don't know what to make of this. So I read the whole thing. And it got very interesting,
very quick. So it's designated a SAP, you know, this is a SAP, it's sitting on a server,
maybe it shouldn't be on. Correct. Right. So I think that's important. And also,
it seems like it's just a response.
To the public spillage or exposure that we saw come forward with people like and specifically
Lou Elizondo, this was like an internal classified response to the fact, oh, shit, some of this is out
now. Yeah, that's exactly the tone of those words of that slide. That's the implied order of events
that led to being established. It was like 2018, maybe. Yeah, the file was at least last accessed
in 2018.
I can't remember if it did say, you know, the file creation date, or if I looked it up,
but I know it was last accessed. Can you see who's accessed it prior to you?
I can. And what did you see? So everyone says that I'm wrong,
it's impossible. But the name I recall, and recalled at the time thinking, oh, that's odd,
was name redacted. And did you know who that was? Vaguely, at that time, I, you know, people are
considered superstars in leadership circles. So you just hear names like that. And that's what
her name was.
Why would that be impossible? Why are people now in retro, why are people telling you that
would be impossible?
Oh, she wasn't at the Pentagon then?
Where was she?
She was at the Pentagon, to my knowledge, but they're saying she wasn't there.
Right. Interesting.
So, all right, so Shriver War Games, you keep reading, there's a big slide with Lou Elizondo's
face on it. What comes next? I mean, you get a sense that I shouldn't be able to read this here.
No, not yet, actually. To be clear, at that point in time, I had no formal training in what SAPs
were. There was no SAP.
Marking on this, just a name, Immaculate Constellation. The opening slide, you know,
just, we would call it improperly labeled, improperly classified.
What was it? What did it show?
So the next slide, the third slide about, just jumps straight into the mission of the SAP and
showing what apparently the results of that mission are. And it's a collection incident
in the Pacific Ocean.
The subject of collection is several Russian naval intelligence vessels in the middle of the ocean
at night. And above those vessels is a large black triangle floating in the air. This is a still
image, but it is a color.
Okay, so that's the first kind of event. But what was the mission? What was the mission? That's what
people want to know is what was the mission of Immaculate Constellation as described in the
product?
So in the product itself, you had to piece together the mission by reading the whole
thing and kind of putting together the parts. You know, it never spelled out fully, like as it
should, the mission of the SAP. And I assume that's because this is a type of brief where
there will be inserts to the deck, which would be inserted by the SAP control officer during
the briefing that would provide another level of detail. But based on the information included
in there, and its description, the mission becomes apparent. And that is,
a bare minimum, it's the Intelligence Surveillance and Reconnaissance mission of globe of a global
nature for UAPs and RVs, ARVs. The hesitation there is some time has passed. One of those
acronyms is in there either RV or ARV. And that is how the triangle in this case was labeled.
It's been seven years. So as you're reading through this, and that you're remembering RV or ARV, just
for our audience.
So RV is, you know, Reversed Reproduction Vehicle. And the ARV would mean
Alien. Anomalous Reproduction Vehicle.
You know, we see, you know, people in the literature say Alien Reproduction Vehicle.
It could just be Anomalous Vehicle or Advanced. It could be anything that can go after A.
So you don't know what that is, but I don't.
This is a pretty interesting image here.
It is. And then the text that accompanies it describes the incident.
And what can you tell us about it?
Yeah.
The summary of that is just the how how it unfolded.
I should I should actually back up and say the image itself was unique.
This isn't by a plane or a satellite.
It it looks to be a image pretty close to the waterline.
So something that to me read is we have a clandestine submersible asset close by this fleet and it's taking pictures trying to stay unnoticed.
And so, yes, in the description, it basically lays out what
what occurred that night, which was that the collection assets were there in area monitoring Russian naval vessels.
Not sure what they're doing there, but they've been hanging out in the middle of the ocean in this place, apparently for a few days.
Keep an eye on him.
And this night, while they are observing the Russian vessels, a large black triangle materializes or decloaks or something.
The point is, is it did not move.
It appeared above the directly above these ships.
Probably no more than 200 meters.
Pretty close.
And interestingly, as noted in the report itself, there is no visible reaction from these vessels from what would almost certainly be considered a hostile approach.
What do you what do you what do you take away from that?
They didn't notice it or they're not upset about it or they don't know what to do with it or what?
So the implication also in the text describing it was or I should say the analysis in the text was that
the Russian Navy had foreknowledge that this vehicle would appear in that area of the ocean and they were there specifically to either collect on it themselves or to interact with it in some way.
Any indication that it might be there that they knew it's going to be there because they control it?
Not in that document.
And I haven't seen anything to make me think that they controlled that particular craft, but didn't see anything to the contrary either.
I guess it could be that they've seen it before.
That there's nothing they can do about it, so don't get excited about it.
Might be, although it is interesting, you know, if it's something that's part of their environment, as it were, why are they making an effort to be in this space at this time to collect on something they already know about?
Is it like in the middle of nowhere?
Yeah, it's off the coast of Kamchatka is, as I recall, in the Pacific Ocean.
That's what struck me.
I mean, my mind goes to the idea that they were kind of camped out, you know, deep kind of ocean.
This one specific area durationally.
It kind of implies to me, if I'm thinking outside the box here, there's some form of comms or communication with whoever the operators are of this craft.
Am I going too far with that idea?
I think it's a reasonable one to have, but it's not one that I can like validate.
Yeah, let's be clear.
You were exposed to something we're just touching the basics here.
We're theorizing.
We're talking about a bunch of stuff we don't know, but the descriptions that you were exposed to kind of give you a sense of what it is.
Yeah.
It does give you a little insight that we can at least look at some of those assumptions.
Right, right.
Absolutely.
And I'm sure there's a literature out there that can help narrow down.
So immaculate constellation.
You've never heard this term before, and it doesn't give you the full picture there.
But what other additional information did it give about what this was and how it operates?
Just describe the events and that analysis of the event of the Russians having foreknowledge to be there and describing
how the event occurred as I just went over.
So this is a page turner.
So, you know, you're interested.
Yeah, you're curious now.
Absolutely.
What do you do next?
What do you go to the next page?
And it was disappointing because we get into a couple slides of orbs, and I had already seen orbs at this point in the official setting.
So the next pages show orbs from different parts of the world.
It looks like the pattern is that there's under this immaculate constellation, they're gathering UAP images from all over the planet.
Absolutely.
I mean, that's the core of it, right?
Right.
Is the idea that we collect data on these UAP and someone needs to bring them, collate them together to provide intel to who needs it.
And we're assuming or not assuming it's been pretty laid out.
The immaculate constellation was a kind of place to bring everything together to provide those briefings to senior leadership.
Is that correct?
I don't know about to provide briefings, but definitely to to collect data from
the military intelligence enterprise specifically and the sensors associated with that.
And yes, to to collect that data, centralize it and have it there for presumably both analysis and, you know, operational needs.
Mm-Hmm.
The Shriver War Games document with the images, 12 pages, 15 pages, somewhere in there.
Yeah, I'd say, yeah, twelve to fifteen, but probably more like twelve.
And is that the only document you ever saw where the term immaculate constellation was used?
Until I wrote one?
Yeah, we'll get into that. But instead of like go through people, we're so curious.
So what comes on the fourth page talks through the pages. Just go ahead.
On the next episode of Weaponized.
When I was in USDI, I read the transcripts of Sean Patrick briefing Senator Rubio, Senator Warren and Senator Gillibrand on the results of his investigation in his congressionally tasked Arrow report.
You know, I read these transcripts once and immediately knew that, yeah, veiled threat.
No, I knew that I was now something else.
I was in I had inside knowledge into the deception of our government by elements of our intelligence community.
My blood ran cold at a specific point in that transcript where Mr. Rubio is discussing the legacy program.
This was a subject of direct discussion.
Sean Kirkpatrick in these meetings and based on Mr. Patrick's replies about as vague as they were, but unable to escape the truth of the legacy program.
Mr. Rubio's response was, well, what the hell is the executive branch doing?
Have they been running this for 60 years without congressional oversight?
The process of Grush coming forward left a wake on the inside, too.
People were tracking that weren't even involved, but were able to see sort of the distortions on the inside.
Distortions of truth.
Exactly.
And but also, you know, bureaucracies and offices behaving weirdly.
That was one of the moments that really started to convince me that this was this was not under under our government's control.